I like to think of it as the world's
first robot lawyer do not pay will have
succeeded if the word lawyer is
completely removed from the dictionary
for average people joshua Browder is
trying to upend the legal services
industry his company do not pay has
built an AI powered chat bot that
interviews users about their legal
problems in plain English then uses
their answers to complete and submit
legal paperwork on their behalf the 21
year old entrepreneur from the UK who
taught himself to code with YouTube
videos lives and works with his
eight-person team out of the same Palo
Alto house that Mark Zuckerberg rented
during his first summer in California
building Facebook do not pay initially
focused on fighting parking tickets and
Browder says it succeeded about half the
time saving users 16 million dollars in
fines over its first three years now
operating on just over a million dollars
in venture capital funding the company
is extending its legal services to a
broad range of issues all free of charge
there are such fundamental issues where
the small of better software can help
millions of people people don't even
know which courthouse to go to or what
documents to file and if you can just
help with that then you can solve maybe
half the problem
you started with parking tickets because
it's a sort of regressive tax and a lot
of people that makes the poorest among
us pay the most and in a lot of these
cases people don't even know that they
do have some recourse right so how do
you educate people and how can they find
out yeah I can help them so for example
for parking tickets actually plays a
game of 20 questions with you to figure
out a legally sound defense it will ask
you was the parking bay too small or
where the signs hard to read so we're
not expecting people to come in knowing
what they can do just if they have any
issue that bothers them come to do not
pay and will get you your money back do
not pay SAP even monitors users accounts
and can automatically repo plane tickets
when prices drop request refunds when
banks charge illegal overdraft fees and
help users reclaim security deposits
from shady landlords the flagship
feature is if you have a problem with
anyone via a corporation or your
neighbor you can sue them by pressing a
button what happens when people actually
get to court to contest these things so
at that point we actually give you a
script which you can read yourself in
the future I think robots will actually
be allowed in court but until that day
comes people actually have to shop
Sal's but they can almost be conduit for
the robot what we give you is very
legally sound and you can actually play
a game of almost learning what you have
to say with the robot lawyer in the app
router says the legal industry is so
ripe for disruption through software
because most services involve nothing
more than standardized processes in
boilerplate language I'm very lucky
although I hate lawyers we actually have
a few good ones who are helping us 50
states with a bunch of different
jurisdictions within them you cover that
entire gamut of different legal
structures yeah at the end of the day
lawyers like to make it seem like the
Laura's rocket science but in reality
the Laura's society's operating system
and the rules should just be able to be
coded without some fancier AI we have
got a bit of it on top but really it's
just a rules-based system given that why
our legal services so expensive right
now if you're a lawyer there's no
incentive to innovate instead you can
just be making millions of dollars a
year by charging clients huge amounts of
money and so because lawyers control the
legal system no one else really
understands it they've kept it that way
and I think it will take people outside
of the legal profession like software to
force them to change and what's your
response to people that say you know
you're building into things like
immigration yes not just a standardized
parking ticket you only have a few
lawyers helping you yeah you can't
possibly be providing the level of
service that a trained legal
professional would I think we really
have a long way to go but on the other
hand if it really is that different for
every person doesn't that mean it's
unfair do you also hope to sort of
incentivize the broader legal system to
become more simple and fair in this way
yes and I think the only way to do that
is by am doing bottom-up approach I like
to think of it as ddossing the legal
system to make it better one of the most
exciting things we have coming out is
something that can get you a DMV
appointment in a few days rather than
months by phoning up the DMV hundreds of
times a day and talking to their
automated scheduling system to try and
look for a cancellation for you so this
sounds great on my end it sounds like a
nightmare from a bureaucrats end or a
regulator or somebody who works the DMV
yeah I have you gotten any pushback on
any of these initiatives we think hard
about doing in an ethical way so we're
only talking to their robots not real
human beings holding up the phone lines
and in fact a lot of governments welcome
do not
when do not pay parking tickets came to
Los Angeles and they said we love it
because people write such gibberish and
there appeals that at least do not pay
Appeals are standardized and well
written so I think that in the long run
and the government's will build their
own systems for dealing with all of this
traffic which will lead to a much fairer
outcome for everyone do not pay doesn't
charge for any of its legal help this
way the company can serve clients who
can't afford to hire lawyers such as
refugees seeking asylum and homeless
people applying for public housing in
the UK the company is also working on a
service that helps navigate the u.s.
visa process all of these processes are
so bureaucratic that if you have no
resources at all it really is impossible
to get the help you need so do not pay
as a completely free public service so
how do you sustain yourself how are you
making money although we have to make
money to sustain ourselves we're not
going to be doing it for charging for
our legal services maybe one day we will
help so many people for example fire
airlines that we will learn how to do an
airline ourselves maybe do not pay
airlines that's a big example but we aim
to replace the people with fighting
that's how we'll make money but I'm not
focused on that at the moment because
everything is fully automated
we're very cost efficient and there are
other similar services or at least ones
that allow you to automatically contest
parking tickets yeah they make money by
taking the slice of the revenue that
they return to people why didn't you
adopt that sort of model 50% of
injustice is still injustice and by
profiting off the problems these
companies actually have an incentive to
perpetuate them which is why they
haven't been solved I think the biggest
example are all these tax filing
services which are now lobbying the
government to keep tax filing
complicated the government has tried to
have a much simpler tax filing process
but the companies publicly listed
companies who they made money off that
sort of thing are saying no we want it
to stay complicated
so do not pay doesn't have any of the
conflict of interest but Browder does
advocate for more consumer protection
laws do not pay never relies on
corporate policies to get customers
money back on things like airline
tickets using only regulations buried in
fine print the way we do it is through
these obscure Department of
Transportation rules that allow the most
non-refundable ticket to become
refundable and that's really important
because laws are hard to change
of course all these corporations have
lobbyists but it's much harder for them
to repeal airline protections than it is
for them to just change a customer
service policy overnight do you feel
that these consumer protections are more
necessary in the airline industry or
because like you were saying earlier a
lot of what you do is help people
navigate complexity the complexity
usually ends up hurting the less
well-off because they're not able to
fund actually going through it don't
have the time so in other areas where
like tax preparation it's better if it's
more simplistic why is the deregulatory
push in the airline space a problem I'm
from the UK and one of the biggest
differences I've noticed between the US
and the UK is that in the u.s. is the
land of the corporation in the UK there
are so many rights that everyone has for
example if the airline changes your
flight time you have a right to cancel I
think that's a very reasonable right for
people to have and do not pay helps
people exercise those rights so it's not
about complexity it's just about giving
people what they deserve and what's just
and fair so in the long run yeah how do
you see do not pay sort of expanding
what space you'd occupying and what do
you think the future is of legal
services once yeah everything can be
automated including a robot lawyer
coming with you to a court room in
Silicon Valley companies like Airbnb and
Twitter have succeeded by adding words
the dictionary you can tweet something
or snap something I think do not pay
will have succeeded if the web lawyer is
completely removed from the dictionary
for average people there's a two hundred
billion dollar legal industry at the
moment and do not pay well hopefully one
day make it free for everyone
[Music]